In 2023 Kurzgesagt has existed for 10 years,
insanely long in internet years. We are among the
largest sciency channels on Youtube and still a
bit of a black box to people. So let us talk about
ourselves a bit in three parts: Our backstory, how
we finance our work and the values of Kurzgesagt!
Let’s jump to a more innocent time.
From humble beginnings to Today
Kurzgesagt’s foundation was laid when Philipp, our
founder, dropped out of high school as a teenager.
Learning seemed daft and useless and he was not
interested in anything. Until a very special
teacher at a school for dropouts grabbed him
by the neck. The way she taught was different.
She talked about connections and the big picture.
She told a story. For the first time ever,
Philipp wanted to learn more without being
forced. It was a key life experience.
Kurzgesagt tries to recreate this
experience for you. Nothing is
boring if you tell a good story
and we try to tell these stories,
to spark excitement and make you
want to go on and learn more.
Because of the one teacher that could do
this, Philipp got a high school degree,
studied history and design and eventually
started Kurzgesagt as a passion project,
inspired by Crash Course World history.
In 2012 Youtube was less commercial and more
idealistic. You couldn’t make a living with
videos as involved as ours and that was fine.
The goal was creative freedom and so for the
first few years, it actually cost money to
make Kurzgesagt. We had no outside funding,
just intrinsic motivation and a few friends from
university. We worked for clients during the day
and on Kurzgesagt at night, 80-100 hours a week.
It was a real struggle but also very rewarding.
But then Patreon launched, sponsorships
started, our views increased, Youtube
changed. In 2015 the channel began to
break even and then to earn a profit.
But we were pretty burned out at this
point, so we decided to bring in more
friends and hire the first team members
full time, creating a legal entity.
More people meant that we could stop overworking,
do more and improve. But we also needed to earn
more; the livelihood of real humans depended
upon it. None of us had any experience in
running a company. We didn’t plan to become
big or to grow – it sorta just happened.
A decade later Kurzgesagt is
not a small project anymore.
We are an animation studio, with offices
in Munich and Berlin. We need computers,
monitors, tablets, desks, coffee, contracts,
pay licences, taxes, rent and insurance.
In 2023 our team consists of over 60 full
employees and a lot of freelancers around
the world. Salaries alone cost millions
of dollars a year, just to stay around.
This creates an interesting problem:
with such high production costs,
how can we publish our work for free?
How we finance Kurzgesagt
We have added up our earnings from 2015 through
2022. Our sources of funding change depending on
opportunities and the state of the world. Early
on, agency work was our main source of income,
ad revenue varies, in some years we got
more sponsorships than in others. The shop
didn’t exist for a long time, then it became
pretty big after we launched our calendar.
62% of our revenue comes
indirectly or directly from you:
You watch our videos with ads, support
us on Patreon or buy from our shop.
The single biggest source of income by far, is
our shop that alone accounted for 40% over the
last 8 years. The shop started small but once we
published our calendar for the first time in 2016,
we realised it could really help us do more
things and we started producing more and
more science products, from our posters to our
gratitude journal or universe scented candles.
YouTube ads accounted for 13% and Patreon 9%.
So without your support we would cease to exist.
Our shop and Patreon are our most important
sources of revenue, and because we see ourselves
as science communicators – we don’t just do
merch, but sciency products that we spend
hundreds of hours researching, discussing with
experts, polishing up and working on directly
with the manufacturers. They are part of the
science story we try to tell. It also just feels
good to get directly funded by you guys and give
you something back for it, on top of our videos.
YouTube ads are a crucial part of our funding
as well, but they are not within our control.
Then there is paid agency work, which we
stopped doing in 2022 – it accounted for
9% of our revenue over the last 8 years. A
lot in the beginning, not much by the end.
Then there are commercial sponsors
advertising products -they accounted
for 12% of our revenue. We also
got about 7% from German Public
Broadcasting for the German Channel,
but ended this partnership in 2022.
Finally there are institutional sponsors
representing about 10%. Some people take
issue with this – especially Bill Gates has come
under public scrutiny, and we’ve been criticised
for even working with organisations funded by
him. So let us look at this 10% in more detail:
About 3% of our revenue over the
last eight years came from the Gates
organisations for a wide variety
of topics, often suggested by us.
5% comes from Open Philanthropy and is only
used for specific projects. With these funds,
we have started Arabic, Hindi, Korean, Japanese,
Portuguese, and French channels, bringing more
free science content to more people. Then there is
a two-year funding for original Tik Tok content,
which gives us freedom to explore and learn
how to do short form science communication.
The final 2% came from other organisations
like the red cross or the UN for example.
We choose institutional sponsors
carefully but if organisations
want to fund videos that help us spread
quality information about relevant topics,
this is an easy yes for us, if we have
the capacity for it. On top of that,
the institutional sponsors we are
working with align with our values.
We have contracts with every grant giver or
sponsor that bars them from editorial influence,
other than suggesting topic areas like
“global health” or “climate change”.
We agree on video topics together, but
sponsors can neither influence details, nor
our conclusions. The final decision always remains
with us. And usually, we develop the topics of the
videos autonomously and tell the sponsor what
we are doing afterwards. If you are interested
in how we research our videos in detail, our
head of research wrote an article about it.
Running an educational youtube channel is a
balancing act that we take very seriously. We
are doing our best to maintain this balance,
adjusting whenever necessary. As a team and
company we want to grow to give more people
access to a science based outlook on the world.
This brings us to our final topic
– why are we doing Kurzgesagt?
Our Values and Our Vision
Our core mission is to spark curiosity. We
want to make science and humanism accessible
for as many people as possible. The effort
we put into creating our videos is a way of
achieving that – our videos are beautiful
because that helps to spark curiosity,
to understand complex topics, and because
it just feels good to create and watch.
Our research is as intensive as it is
so our videos are a good simplification
of very complicated topics. We want
to make people excited about science
so they rediscover subjects they hated
in school and see how amazing they are.
On top of curiosity, we want to inspire long term
thinking and a positive, constructive outlook.
Being optimistic about the future of humanity
is not mainstream and we think this is horrible.
Pessimism often sounds smart and
gets more views while optimism can
sound naive but this is a bias that
is not helpful for us as a species.
So despite the gloominess of many topics,
we want to approach them with informed and
well researched optimism – not brushing
humanity's very real challenges aside,
but also not falling into the trap of pessimism.
We want to inspire you to dream a little about
the glorious future that we could actually
build – but only if we believe it is possible.
In the long run we don’t only want to do this
on Youtube. The idea is for Kurzgesagt to be a
positive influence across more media. On our
Tik Tok channel, in the long form content we
are exploring, in apps, in the VR game that will
be released later this year and the games we plan
to make in the future. Our shop is a central part
of this vision: we start our stories with a video
and end them with a pos
ter.
There are so many things we want to do. And
thanks to you watching this right now, we have
the freedom to work to the best of our knowledge
and ability. In the end, we hope you like what
we offer and that we will be doing something
worthwhile for as long as we exist. And hopefully,
we’ll have a lasting impact by making science and
learning more fun for as many people as possible.
If you personally want to help us do this, you can
watch and share our videos, check out our shop,
become a patreon or give us an ad blocker
exception. We exist because of you and
you have no idea how much we appreciate that
you are here. And hopefully we are less of a
black box now. In any case. Doing Kurzgesagt
for a decade has been a pretty crazy ride.
So from the whole team – Thank you so
much for being with us all these years.